A warm welcome to Noomi Rapace.
Welcome!
It's hard to believe you're here.
I read about you in the papers,
and you're hugely productive.
-Do you have a clear grasp of it all?
-No.
I forget which country I'm in,
I mix up languages, and I feel...
I lose the outer structure,
but my inner radar is pretty clear.
-You're in Stockholm, just FYI.
-Right, I landed today.
You're here for the movie premiere
of "The Drop".
We'll see a clip from that later,
but you're also making another film?
No, we finished a week ago.
I injured my foot, so my walk is wonky.
-You picked the right shoes, then.
-I know.
-What happened?
-Painkillers.
No, I jumped...
On the last night of shooting...
It's like a female Bourne,
and I play a CIA agent.
-Jason Bourne, but female. Wow!
-Right.
So I run, shoot, fight,
and survive a lot-
-while trying to save people
for about two hours or so.
On the last night, I jumped out a window
while escaping this house-
-and I'm supposed to jump this fence
in heels.
I landed on the foot and something
happened to the ball of my foot.
I've been partly disabled for a week.
And for the film, "The Drop",
what did you have to do?
Well, I went to strip clubs in New York
for research.
What? I've seen the film;
there are no strip clubs.
No, it's more to do with her back story.
If there are any omissions or gaps,
I have to...
If there's a pause in a scene,
I need to fill it.
"What is she thinking,
what has she gone through?"
In order to build a back story,
sometimes I have to do research.
I think that she... In one scene,
we find out she wanted to be a dancer-
-but it didn't work out, so I think
she started stripping instead.
I talked to the director, and he agreed.
So I did research in strip clubs-
-and at a rescue center for dogs.
So it was dogs and naked women...
I met you not too long ago, by chance,
in a bar in London.
And I was... I really felt
how old I've become.
I was heading out to go to bed,
and I felt like the most boring person.
You had your little umbrella,
and you looked like a little old man.
I really did! I saw myself
the way you saw me.
-I wanted to be more...
-I think we were just heading out.
-The night had just started for you.
-Right, right.
And I just went in and then to bed.
I was thinking about you, and you're
so energetic. Are you also restless?
-Is that always a good thing?
-No.
It depends on what you do with it.
I've found a way to channel my energy
and my pace.
It can get rather messy if you're
out of sync with everyone else-
-and I have been in the past.
I got started as others finished-
-got tired, or didn't want to work more.
When I was younger-
-I had always just started
when others were ready to finish.
That can make you feel lonely
or sort of...
You can end up out of step
if you don't find a release.
To me, acting is the perfect...
It's the perfect channel
to get it all out.
Now that we filmed "Unlocked",
I get up to work out in the mornings-
-no matter how early the call time is,
even if it's 4 or 5 AM.
We shoot throughout the day,
and I work out in the evening again.
-Then I can sleep well.
-Is there an escape in all of this?
Absolutely, I think so.
I find it hard to stop.
And I find it scary to have...
...a day without any plans, but I don't
remember when I had one last.
But for the first time in my life,
I actually long for it now.
I actually long for
a time without any plans.
To be able to wake up and take the days,
or weeks even, as they come.
I don't think I've ever
longed for that before.
When you're successful,
people often ask how it has changed you.
Most say, "not at all, I'm the same".
But I'll ask - has it changed you?
Has it changed you, somehow?